in our series a more perfect union we
have to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning how a volunteer
is giving Southern California seniors
the Hollywood treatment Matthew Hoffman
is an energetic TV host who's found a
way to turn his passion for movies like
Braveheart into scene-stealing moments
for his students take ry
[Applause]
Oakland leads a weekly class at the
Senior Center called Tuesdays with
Matthew I want to take this class Jamie
you guys went along to see one of his
classes Jamie good morning I have to say
it is fun being in that class Anthony
Tuesdays with Matthew is a class where
seniors all the way up to 97 years old
recreate famous scenes from famous films
and the movie magic is transforming
lives actors in their golden years
reliving scenes from the Golden Age of
Hollywood frankly my dear I don't give a
damn it's hard to tell who has more fun
the students or the teacher I just
wanted to take him home and keep him but
he won't you don't come home with me
these people I see them more than I see
anybody period hands down here we go
Matthew Hoffman moved to Hollywood 15
years ago with the dream of becoming a
TV host but he needed an audition real I
used to drive by the Senior Center every
single day I was like I'll go into the
Senior Center and I'll interview these
funny seniors get my bits and that'll be
it I love you once inside Hoffman was
inspired by the people he met nice to
see you
he created a scene study class Tuesdays
with Matthew it's a man's world down
here and it changed my life
they have literally like crafted me
transformed me in what way I have
learned so much about being an adult
kindness compassion to feed his creative
needs
Matthew began to turn scenes into mini
movies from Toto to a twister there's a
part for everyone
like home
I got so caught up in how funny the
movies could be how entertaining the
movies could be that it really started
to turn into a vanity project what do
you get out of Matthew singing and music
and reading these scripts I forget my
pain I have serious spinal stenosis
Matthew doesn't give up on anybody
Matthew not only directs he creates
costumes and props many live in the back
of his Ford Fiesta this is my Audrey
Hepburn wig for the Breakfast at
Tiffany's of course no movie would be
complete without a premiere where
families are invited to toast the night
with ensure
even though we're older he's still a
role model for me you're learning a lot
more than just acting in this class yes
because I'm learning how to treat people
and how to be kinder Hoffman doesn't get
paid for this gig that's why he has to
keep his day job traveling the world to
interview celebrities the forecast is
hot and oh my he's also the narrator of
the CBS reality show love island and
find there were some people who are
crying a lot of people thought I was not
coming back
what if he can't make a class
disappointment devastation Long Island
but while success has made his work-life
volunteer balance a challenge Hoffman
says the bond here is unbreakable
get off Instagram go for an hour change
somebody's life now even change your
life make their afternoon and I think
that if anybody can do that and to
volunteer you will be so transformed it
will change your life and Hoffman tells
us that he hopes what he's doing catches
on across the country that everyone
finds their Tuesday in a volunteer
opportunity just what a great guy number
one he looks sort of like Jim Carrey did
a little bit angles but toasting was in
Shore and just what he's done for the
people how much they so enjoy that I
think what's great is that those groups
are getting so much she's out of it age
is not a number he considers these
people his friends I love the reaction
in the audience which is much fun
performances the whole thing is fabulous
it's very fun one of my favorite stories
in a long time yeah Jamie
you like your Matthew